what I want to do in this video is take
an expenditure view of GDP so that we
can think about how GDP could be
accounted for how it can be measured and
how we can see what the how active the
different parts of an economy actually
are so GDP market value of all final
goods and services produced not just
changed hands produced within a country
in a given period and the symbol we use
for GDP and I don't know why but the
symbol is why why is GDP and so let's
think about it from an expenditure point
of view expenditure point of view to
think about what are all the pieces well
if we're thinking about expenditure who
are all of the players that might have
spent money on goods and services on
final goods and services produced in our
country who are all the people that
might have done it
well you could have your firm's the
firm's might have spent money on these
goods and services produced in a country
you also have your households they
obviously could have spent spent some
money on goods and services produced in
this country then you also have you also
have in most countries in fact in all
countries you have the government the
government could have spent some of the
money on the goods and services produced
in this country and if we assume that
we're trading with other countries there
are other countries that might have bent
money on goods and services other
outside so let's just write foreign
people outside of the country might have
spent money on goods and services
so foreign foreign purchases and another
way to think about this would have been
this is this is exports our country is
exporting it to people outside of the
country and they are purchasing it now
this is almost complete
but if we looked at all of the money
that firms are spending and all the
money that households are spending and
all the money that governments are
spending some of what they're spending
might not be on goods and services that
are produced in this country they might
be spending some of their stuff on
things that are produced outside of this
country so we would have to subtract it
out if we really want to have the goods
and services produced within the country
so what we're going to want to do is
subtract out what foreign products
foreign foreign products or in products
or another way that a more typical way
of thinking about it we would subtract
out imports so if we think about all of
the goods and services that meet these
classification the final goods and
services produced in the country in a
given time produced spent that firm
spent money on and add that to all the
goods and services that households spent
money on and I'll add that to the goods
and services government spent on and all
the goods and services that were
purchased by foreigners the exports and
then make sure we're not counting the
goods and services that other countries
produce so we subtract those out this
would give you a pretty good measure of
all of the goods and services produced
within a country and this is pretty
close to way the economists actually do
measure it so what they do what they do
is they say Y is equal to investment
investment and we saw in a previous
video investment in the macroeconomics
term isn't quite what it means in the
everyday terms it really essentially
means the spending by firms so pretty
much everything that a firm spends in
theory they're spending that money to
make future goods and services so or to
make goods and services so that's all
considered investment and then there's a
little bit of household for a little bit
of the household spending is considered
investment and that is just new houses
new new houses but the bulk of household
spending is considered to be consumption
is considered to be consumption is
considered to be consumption and then
everything that the government spends on
whether it's the military and all the
salaries for police people and and and
you know whatever they do you know the
the groundskeeping of at the White House
whatever else if we're thinking about
the US that it that goes straight to gee
government spending and this thing right
over here you have foreign purchases
exports minus foreign imports so you
have exports minus imports so you could
view this as net exports net exports if
this number is positive the net exports
are positive we're exporting more than
we're importing if this number is
negative next net exports is negative
that means we're importing more than we
are exporting but in the traditional
expenditure view of GDP
this whole part right over here will be
referred to as net exports net net
exports and so you sum up these things
which are very closely related to maybe
the slightly more intuitive versions
that we started off with and you
essentially have broken down the
expenditure view of GDP in the
traditional sense and in the next few
videos I'm going to start thinking of a
bunch of different examples and we'll
think about which bucket it would fall
into or how it would affect one of these
buckets